-Welcome back. We're here with
Stephen A. Smith right here.
Now, Stephen, we love you.
You're known
for your strong opinions
about all kinds
of different topics.
So with that in mind, it's time
to play a game we call
Wheel of Opinions.
Here we go.
-Let's do it.
-♪ Wheel of Opinions ♪
-Now here's how it works.
I'm going to hit this button
here, which activates
the opinion topic generator,
and it will land
on a random topic.
Whatever it is, you have
to give an opinion on it.
-Do I hit the button
or do you hit the button?
-I'll hit the button so you
don't have to worry about that.
-Alright. Okay.
I appreciate that.
-I don't want you to have to
worry about this stuff.
You're a guest on the show,
come on.
-I appreciate that, man.
That's first class.
-Yeah, of course.
-That's first class right there.
Here we go.
♪♪
-Ooh.
-How about fans
who paint their chests?
-Oh, Lord.
-What's your thoughts?
-Something's wrong
with those people.
Now, I want to say this.
I want to say this.
It's wrong with them,
but in certain college -- like,
festive college atmosphere,
those big time football games,
the basketball games,
the tailgate parties
that precede it --
alright, that's fine.
However, however, I don't know
what's wrong with these people
who do that in cold weather.
Like you're in Ohio,
at Ohio State.
Yeah.
-And it's 5 degrees
and you out there half-naked.
You're at Michigan, Ann Arbor,
half naked.
Now, if you did that in
Pasadena,
okay, I'll let you.
-Okay.
-But when you do that
in the cold weather,
let me --
let me put to you this way.
Ain't no Black people
doing that.
[ Laughter ]
Ain't no Black people
doing that.
We ain't doing that cold stuff.
-Okay. Yeah, okay. Gotcha.
That's good. Okay.
Let's get to the next topic
♪♪
-Oh!
-Gatorade showers.
-Very nasty.
Now, don't get me wrong --
if you need your electrolytes,
it works.
It works.
But, you know --
and it don't matter when you win
because it don't matter --
I mean, listen,
most people,
if you notice, when they win it,
whether it's the champagne
or it's the water or whatever,
is coming with funk.
They're going to
stink afterwards, okay?
Because you're sweating,
and the water hits you.
But when there's Gatorade,
it's sticky.
-Sticky.
-And that's just nasty.
-Yeah. You don't want sticky.
-That's just nasty,
but you tolerate it
because you ain't getting
Gatorade poured on you
unless you won.
I've never seen a loser
get Gatorade poured on them.
[Bell dings]
I've never seen that.
-Here we go.
♪♪
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry -- Look, hey.
-Why you doing this?
-We got security by the door
in case something happens.
Knicks or Lakers?
Holy moly.
What's happening?
-Believe it or not...
Believe it or not...
The Lakers are worse.
-Wow.
-Here's the reason why.
-Yeah, tell us.
-Are we really surprised
the Knicks lost?
Where's the suspense?
I mean, I'm disappointed.
-I see what you're saying.
-But most people expected...
-Yeah.
-At the very best,
a late first round exit --
at the most, second round,
you going home.
You had LeBron.
-Okay.
-Anthony Davis.
Russell Westbrook.
-Tinsel Town, purple and gold,
Hollywood, statues
of Shaq and Magic
and Kareem outside,
and Kobe and -- boy, I mean --
And you are like 17, 18 games
under 500.
You know, stealing money
from the public,
ain't thinking about
giving it back.
I mean, look --
-The Knicks not --
-Look, look, look, look.
Give the Knicks credit
for this --
they've been honest.
[ Bell dings ]
♪♪
Just saying.
[ Crowd gasps ]
-Tom Brady un-retiring.
-You know what that's about,
right?
Y'all don't notice.
Allow me to help you out.
My brother.
Tom Brady didn't un-retire.
Giselle un-retired.
You think so?
-Oh, no, that brother --
that brother said
she sat up there in 2017.
She told the world, "Y'all ain't
got to live with him
when this is over.
He comes home to me.
I love my man.
Concussions, concussions,
and all of this other stuff.
I want him heathy."
-Yeah.
-Finally, couple of
Super Bowl titles later,
-Yeah.
-Actually, three to be exact,
she sat up there and said,
"He said, 'Hey, it's time.
I'm-a give it up.
I'm-a hang it up."
-Done.
Went home for two weeks.
[ Laughter, bell dings ]
And then said, "I think
I'm going to un-retire."
[ Laughter ]
That wasn't about Tom Brady.
That was about the wife saying,
"I love you,
but you -- I may have made
an error in my thinking.
You might need
to go home, okay?"
Because listen, Tom Brady,
the brother's fly --
looks very good.
Looks like a GQ model.
Rocks the Tom Ford blazers,
the whole bit.
Yeah, but, you know, we see him
when he out in public.
-Yeah.
-We don't see him when he home
with T-shirts and shorts,
walking around the house.
And if you Giselle, you like,
"Wait, wait, wait a minute.
You sure you want to stay home?
Maybe I should support you
more."
"I should support you more
and you should go back to work."
-That's right, go back to work.
-Go back to work, sweetheart,
and I'll see you
when you get home.
That's what she did.
That was Giselle un-retiring.
-Alright. I'll take that.
I like that.
-That's what that was about.
♪♪
-It's our last question.
-Easily. Easily.
-The greatest of all time.
-Easily.
-Wait, wait.
You're saying easily.
-Yes, Michael Jordan.
-Really?
-Easy. Easy. Easy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But you know what
the difficult part is?
Is LeBron number two
or number three,
to Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
being number two?
-Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
-Sky high. Sky high.
-19-time All-Star,
six-time champion,
six-time league MVP,
all time leading scorer
in NBA history,
and the only individual
in the history of the sport
with one unstoppable move
year after year after year
spanning decades that no one
can still figure out.
That's Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
-Yeah.
-And won a title
for UCLA in college,
and won a title at Powell
Memorial in New York City
before he went to college.
LeBron James is phenomenal.
He's on the Mount Rushmore
of basketball.
He's all that and
a bag of chips.
But he did lose six NBA finals.
-Okay. Yeah.
-And he is the star on a team
that is presently
18 games --
-Wait, wait. [ Laughs ]
[ Bell dings ]
That's it.
He settles it right there.
Jordan and Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
Stephen A. Smith, everybody.
Watch him weekdays on ESPN,
"First Take,"
And "Stephen A.'s World"
on ESPN Plus.
That was fantastic.
Come back whenever you want.